بدايه واضح بان قوات الاحتلال لديها رغبه
تدبريه جامحه وكبيره هنا في خانيونس حيث
عمليات النسف والقصف مستمره من قبل اليات
الاحتلال وجنود الاحتلال لمربعات سكنيه في
وسط المحافظه وكذلك في منطقه شرق معسكر
خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه عمليات القصف
استمرت حتى هذه الساعه وكذلك القصف
المدفعي مستمر في منطقه حي المناره وكذلك
في الاجزاء الشرقيه لمحافظه خان يونس
اضافه الى ما تقوم به ال الاحتلال بعمليات
تجريف لمنازل المواطنين في منطقه المعسكر
مخيم اللاجئين في غرب المحافظه وكذلك
منطقه حي الامل المشروع ايضا في غرب
محافظه خانو الاليات ما زالت تتواجد في
هاتين المنطقتين وتقوم باطلاق وب الكثيف
من قذائفها المدفعيه باتجاه منازل
المواطنين في ظل ايضا احتدام اشتباكات ما
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
في هاتين المنطقتين تحديدا بالقرب من مسجد
الرحمه في حي الامل كذلك منطقه الصناعه او
مركز تدريب التابع للوكاله في غرب محافظه
خانيونس وكذلك في محيط مقبره النمساوي الى
الاجزاء الغربيه الجنوبيه من معسكر
خانيونس الاشتباكات لا تتوقف ما بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال بين
الحين والاخر ايضا هناك عمليات اطلاق
قذائف من قبل المقاومه خاصه قذائف الهوم
باتجاه تجمعات وتحشد لاليات الاحتلال في
اكثر من منطقه سواء في المناطق الشرقيه
للمحافظه وحتى في الاجزاء الغربيه من
المحافظات حركه النزوح في هذا في هذا
اليوم اقل من الايام الماضيه خاصه بعدما
وصل الى مسامع المواطنين بعمليات التنكيل
التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال للنازحين في
باتجاه الممر الذي ده الاحتلال انه ممرا
انسانيا لكن المواطنون بعدما سمعوا الى
شهادات المواطنين الذين نجحوا في الوصول
الى ذلك الممر وعمليات التنكين التي قامت
بها قوات الاحتلال باتجاه المواطنين
واعتقال ايضا اعداد كبيره من المواطنين
دفع هؤلاء المواطنين الى التواجد والبقاء
في مناطق غرب خانيونس واللجوء الى مستشفيي
سواء مستشفى الامل او مستشفى ناصر في
محافظه خنوس باعتبارهما اكثر امنا من
المناطق التي يتواجدون فيها في مخيم
اللاجئين او حتى في منطقه حي الامل